learners permit thursdays on my youtube
subscribe today hey guys i just want to
say thank you to all the fans in
cleveland who came out to the shows i
had a blast in your hometown la jolla
i'm headed your way next week friday
december 17th through the 19th
unfortunately austin is gonna have to be
rescheduled the club will not be open in
time they just inform me um and we're
looking for another date for that for
all information and all tickets go to
ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com and ryan sickler on all your
social medias social medias whatever you
know where it's at uh the night pants
nation tour is out there austin i'll be
there january 6th through the 8th get
all your tickets at ryanstickler.com
join the email list you'll be the first
to know all the upcoming stuff before
anybody else and please if you're
watching on youtube hit the subscribe
i'm telling you it means nothing you and
everything to all of us it's nothing i
see half of you watching and not hitting
subscribe just [ __ ] flick it just
flick it and the patreon show look
i
it's taken me a long time to be able to
actually say i love my job i love my
[ __ ] job and i can't pick which show
i like to do better all right the
patreon is the honeydew with you all and
y'all
have the craziest stories i've ever
heard in my life it's five bucks a month
and if you sign up for a year you get
over a month free all right and you get
the honeydew a day early ad free no
additional cost all right um if you or
someone you know has that story submit
it to honeydewpodcast gmail.com
hopefully we get to do an episode
together all right you know what we do
over here we highlight the low lights i
like to find a little bit of light in
the darkness and today's guest here
first time on the honeydew very excited
to have him ladies and gentlemen please
welcome right along welcome to the
honeydew ryan we got a couple ryan's
rocking out here in l.a
i appreciate you being here you kind of
look like a little like you could be we
could be in the same family too you look
like my brother a little do i yeah
there's a lot you know like reynolds
there's a lot of ryan's and they all
kind of got the same look around here
you got the eyes we have the eyes yeah
you got the same eyes yeah yeah
um well welcome thank you for doing the
show i've never even met you before so
yeah i asked around a lot of people
volunteered information about you being
a good dude so i was like all right
let's have fun so dude that's one thing
i found about america when i came here
people were cool man it's uh that's one
thing that's better about america than
where i'm from toronto because it's
smaller everyone here is very much more
like down to help out and they want to
you know people want people see people
that they think is cool and they go i
want to like work with that guy connect
with whereas where i'm from it's more
like who's this guy trying to show up
and steal stuff i don't feel like it's
always been like that but you're right
lately especially like there's a lot of
the industry yeah i mean people are
really reaching down and pulling each
other up and pushing people like you
know look
if you've been in the game long enough
and and you're out for something and you
know damn well it's not right for you
why not be like you know who'd be great
for that this person you don't need to
be in everything sometimes you're in
everything at the detriment of your [ __ ]
you know what i mean like i like to just
produce stuff like i'm not right for
that yeah but i i got the right mindset
for that i just don't think i'd be good
in that i know it is it's a huge tweak i
feel like you can make in your own self
when like
when you see something good or someone
doing something good and it kind of
jazzes you up as opposed to makes you
mad i feel like that yeah [ __ ] yeah that
magic is back like you see that person's
getting it yeah oh hell yeah yeah you
know
um all right well before i get to know
you a little better here please plug
promote everything anything you'd like
yeah man i do a podcast called the boys
cast with ryan long every friday and
patreon.com the boyscast youtube.com
ryan long comedy i do a interview i do a
video sketch every monday and then a
street interview every wednesday and i
got two specials uh comedy specials out
there and one coming out in mid-january
too so check it out
tell me about the street interviews what
is that all about so i came uh
i was like a uh just when i was like 12
even i was the biggest like tom green
guy so i feel like me and everyone
you're canadian yeah we're all doing an
impression of tom at the time right but
i did uh so i had this uh
i used to do all these dvds i was in
this band and we did all these dvds
messing with people even before when you
can when you couldn't put them on the
internet straight up just cutting them
to show your friends and stuff like that
and i was doing all sorts of that stuff
i did a few tv shows doing that kind of
stuff in canada messing around with
people on them when i moved here that
was the first thing i was like you know
what i don't really know anyone i don't
have a crew anymore i was like that's
the one thing i could do super easy so i
just started kind of doing the stuff
i've been doing in canada on my youtube
channel here and it kind of a lot of
stuff was going viral and stuff
so go back to the beginning you're from
canada where toronto i'm from ajax right
right outside of toronto okay some 41.
uh snow went to my high school the
rapper informer
i got a good snow story
don't please my buddy and i used to
still we'll still all right 12 inches
what is it 12 inches of snow and rising
isn't it it is right yeah he had some
stuff that didn't uh age well either
legal tender and fine i don't know i
only
you know this one goes league ten that
run fine and the idea is like she turned
18 yesterday oh my god
i remember one the one video informer on
mtv day one here and we used to be like
who the [ __ ] is this yeah yeah he went
to becker and i for a second but so he
was my friend uh danny paul chuck who i
do all this stuff with he's kind of he's
on my podcast and stuff and we did uh
he made a movie that i kind of helped
write on and i was in it a little bit
but it's his thing and they wanted to
put snow the rapper in it because he was
on this tv show they did blah blah right
so
the premise was they had this character
and they're like snow would be hilarious
for it and the bit was
one of the tiny things he did was snow
talks to the cops in one of the scenes
and he goes listen i want to do this but
i can't do any role where i would talk
to the cops because i would never inform
even in a movie
and he's like my boy's like that's what
it is that's my brand that i don't talk
to the cops and they're like yeah i
think they'll get that it's like a
character
dude he doesn't even inform that even
like even
like yeah his friends are gonna be like
hey what's this we hear about you
talking to the cops he goes it's a movie
they go on
you couldn't talk to the cops
he stayed true all the way man
25 years ago this song came out 12
inches of snow yeah he's gonna start
getting booed at his shows now like this
is how he's living right but the fact
that you have to say snow the rapper
when you have to throw the rapper on
like chance is different this guy was
called the rapper first because nobody
knew who the [ __ ] that guy was yeah
who's what's snow what are you talking
about the rapper the rap the i guess the
reggae guy really he just started doing
a reggae accent and then popped off man
so all right ajax outside of toronto
suburb i was a little skateboard forming
bands standard kind of
you know what were your parents like
what did they do for a living so my dad
uh
they were like they owned some music
stores
and then so i was like well as my
grandfather does and then my dad that's
what we're doing and right now santa
monica music center this kind of music
store yeah so it's a more like family
store no like instruments yeah yeah so
him and uh like my my family's all very
musical me and my you know a lot of the
cousins aren't involved things fall
apart of the third generation usually
you know that's what it is yeah well
it's because it is that challenge it is
you know every company like that well
the fir like if your dad starts
something and he wants to take it over
you're kind of like i could make this my
thing if it was already someone else
already did that you can't really make
it your thing so all you can do is if
you if people want third generation to
sort of get involved in the thing i feel
like these days you really just have to
make them a piece of [ __ ] where you go
you know what we'll just give you way
too much money for this so no one really
wanted to do that no one wants to do it
so um none of us are really that
involved but that's that and then they
um
my mom grew up in the projects
the hood
yeah what's the projects projects like
ontario housing yeah yeah uh
wild family my mom's like just irish
[ __ ] trash right
dude
are you close with your mom yeah
dude
do my mom she's like she she it comes
out every now and then where
uh something will happen and she's like
very nice lady and tell something like
she gets like what the [ __ ] you want to
come at me and i'm like what is this and
we go right that's the hood
but uh like this is the kind of way she
grew up like her two brothers both died
of like heroin and you know in and out
of
pretty wild stuff right
uh like went uh he was like a
the the one would would kind of go to my
grandmother's house like steal
everything
like that all the classic
problems but you know and then half you
know her other two brothers they have
their life together and they have jobs
and the other two are dead now and
that's kind of what it was did you ever
meet them or are they gone yeah yeah you
did one had uh my one uncle that he died
first he had a he had to skull it like
straight up like he kind of looked like
me like for real he kind of looked like
me but bald up here and just tall hair
yeah
like ben franklin proper too he wasn't
messing around where it's like a little
bit this is cultivated he'd have a hat
on the hat come off and go wow
he was a wild man did you ever how old
was he when you passed uh i think
probably four years ago and then oh wow
that's i gotta go this is a joke i'm
gonna tell the joke version but it is
real so
my uncle he died right my grandmother
was like kind of getting dementia so
the when he died it was very like do we
tell her do you tell her that her son's
dead and my mom was kind of her idea was
you know what she can she's not really
all there
she might die let's not
so we didn't tell her then she kind of
started getting better like
and she
but my mom was sad
[Laughter]
dude my mom was dead on it too because i
there was some disagreement on i'm sure
you know all right she's getting better
we got to say something
[ __ ] your mom's like anybody says [ __ ]
you shut the [ __ ] up
like you i wish a [ __ ] would
cross me
we could dig two hoes [ __ ] we
could dig two hoes yeah you want to join
them
so
well it's the story ended positively
because she's dead too so
it worked itself
family things and she's still like you
pop back in sometimes and be like he
never visits me anymore and i would i
this is a joke where i would be like
we'd have to be like that piece of [ __ ]
yeah he's dead to us
now what about your other uncle uh he
died probably 10 years ago and do you
remember him as well yeah it was it was
kind of a wild thing where for real made
my face twist bro dude it was it was one
of those things where i don't know if
you have this as much here but
like you know he would
people in the family would legitimately
run into this guy and he'd be begging
for change outside of a
uh like beer store or whatever and you'd
see him my brother i remember he ran
into he was on a date with some chick
people started dating he's
going to get beer and it's like uncle
ray like you know they see each other
and it's heaven what oh and you're just
like
it's one of those things where
you know it's anyone who's been in that
situation like obviously the
instinct is like well you have money
give him money but he's like doesn't
work like that you give him money and
the money's gone and then they're that
they're this a week later you know so
it's a weird situation and you like oh
you come stay with us for a bit it's
like you know then they're gone and your
stuff's gone it's a situation that's
gotta be trippy to see your relative in
the streets begging for money tough
right yeah yeah and it's mostly it's
toughest for her and i think a lot of
people in the family also have
the
you know some anger like especially the
my other uncles you know i don't know
you are like the relationship exactly
with your mom but imagine you had a
brother that came in like she's like she
don't have that much money she's on like
a pension or whatever and then your
brother comes and like steals her last
little bit of money like they're
you know they're
some of them is a little like he ever
shows his face around here he better
[ __ ] stay on the streets you know so
it's a lot of uh it's a tense situation
kind of all around and no one knows what
to do about it there's no good answer to
those things when people are on
addicted to crack you know so your mom
had four brothers yeah and and her or
their sisters too yeah two four brothers
no sisters and so she still has two that
are alive still yeah they all get along
uh the two the yeah everyone that's
alive still gets along i mean i get it
man your mom does come from it sounds
like a hard upbringing i like look
i'm guilty of this myself like i have to
i have to learn a little bit more
patience i think because
i forget not everybody grew up the way i
grew up and my tolerance for [ __ ] is
zero yeah you know what i mean but this
person over here but i'm running it
through my filter yeah this person that
my dumb thing that i think is dumb it
might be wrecking them and i'm over like
what the [ __ ] the big deal you know
what i mean because i got to learn to be
probably a little more sensitive but i
can't help it it's just you know i think
i feel like i'll always have my
shoulders up i think that's like one of
those things that helps you for
everything where you go
just remember
not only do people see the same world as
you but like even on top of that be like
remember that not everyone wants the
same [ __ ] as you like how many times
have you you know you're like in
entertainment you're doing well like how
many times in your life have you been
working with someone where you're like
yo what like what the and like they
don't want to take over the world the
same way you might like so you you keep
putting your [ __ ] on them there's like
why doesn't this guy want to work 16
hours a day it's like because they don't
care about this that much like they're
some people's goals might be
all right i just want to like have you
know make a decent living have my family
like watch tv have a free time and like
that might be actually the smarter of
the two like your way we might actually
say all the time i just want to go cut
the [ __ ] grass yeah yeah i mean like
people ask me on the road like it's so
cool you do i'm like what are you doing
like i don't know what are you doing
this weekend i don't know sunday i'm
just going to cut the grass i'm like a
ride mower and like yeah i'm like yeah
how much i'd love to just [ __ ] cut
the grass just chill just cut the grass
grab a beer throw some throw some music
and just [ __ ] smoke
it's a ride yeah i don't even i just
start smoking start smoking for the
moment
dip and chew and smoking just to [ __ ]
get the full experience i would love to
yeah grass is always green why not
that's what they say but you know i read
a quote recently it said the grass is
always greener where you water it not
the other side where you [ __ ] water
it yeah i think so all right so that's
your mom tell me about your dad yeah
pretty uh my dad's a good dad he's like
uh like we're like we were big i was uh
very much
you know i'm sorry is his family the
music yeah they got the music stores
everyone's almost everyone's musical
like my grandma and my grandfather
started this little jazz band and
they're in like the music hall of fame
and stuff like that oh [ __ ] yeah jack
long trio and my grandmother played so
like at my family gatherings
they they get the band they legitimately
have a they go they have a music set up
where the where the gatherings are and
everyone plays music and
they do uh my grandmother plays piano my
grandpa plays trumpet and they get the
band back together and everyone goes up
and sings and people are very talented
in that family like my my my cousin just
uh emily long she's uh
she just did uh you know the top
musician in canada under 20 or something
like that damn okay yeah like all this
stuff and there's a lot of very talented
people in that family yeah what do you
play instruments so i was so i was
probably which is the funny part i don't
think i'm the most talented but i was
probably the most successful musician in
the family because when i was a kid i
started this band called the john stones
and then
by the time i was like in first year
college we were wait how old were you
when you started the band then well yeah
high school 16 14. earlier yeah then uh
but then they all you know you're in a
when you're a band kid you're just in a
bunch of bands and then one kind of
sticks so we had this one band that
stuck we were kind of doing well by
grade 12 by like first year college we
were like on mtv and we had a bunch of
hits on the countdown and we were
selling tickets and doing all this stuff
so i feel like a lot of the things that
i
know now i like learned from a ton of
the mistakes that i made like the first
round the first round's rough like when
you see people hitting the first round
at 35 and you go ah you could have used
a round at 20. yeah i could have used
all kinds of rounds earlier on
there's so much stuff that
is happening now
that i [ __ ] i'm like nah i did i've been
through this already i know who to
listen to i know when to listen to
myself i know
when you're just
i know when you're
being successful because you're good and
i know what part of it are successful
because you're on a wave and how to
distinguish the two like there's so many
people that are part of a wave and
they're and you like i'm great and it's
like nah you're the right place right
time but sometimes you are great and i
think knowing when those are
you know you know you can make the right
decisions right
so were your parents what what did your
dad do for a living he worked at the
store all stores stores yeah so how did
your parents meet
my dad was playing in a band and he was
playing bass when he was young when he
was like you know 24 or whatever he said
hey hey baby from the projects you know
[Laughter]
my mom's cute you know big tits little
package
but they're divorced they got they were
uh i would say
probably they're a terrible pair like
when you look back and you go how did
you guys stay together ever how were you
when they split maybe like 12 13.
yeah right around the time you formed
the band yeah when i was like i would
think my brothers
oh uh my one brother he has a little
uh energy of it was kind of hard whereas
me i'm like i don't think i even noticed
i remember my mom when she when she told
me she goes
listen like me and your dad are getting
like divorced and just want you to know
we don't love you any less and i
remember being like yeah i mean why
would you love me last like what
like first of all
like i could not care less i'm like can
i go skateboard now like i don't care
you you go logistically you're just like
is this gonna be like a big pain in the
ass for me but it wasn't they moved a
few you know a few miles apart we didn't
have to go to different schools it
really changed the only thing that
happened was because i was kind of like
a getting kicked out of school kid and
stuff like that the only thing now is
that it's easier to get away with
everything
but
the nightmare
the nightmare
my horror is that you got to do
everything twice like now especially
like i you know if i go back to canada i
got to do two things if you start dating
a girl they got divorce parents it's
like
a lot of parents in the mix these days
with all these divorces
going to see all these [ __ ] people
yeah they love it it's not vacation it's
visiting yeah there's a big difference
it's too much there's too much of that
right now so that's that's the pain in
the ass that came with it so your mom
and dad they split who do you live with
them mom live with uh pretty even but
mom but like 70 30. okay yeah because
they live not that far away and did mom
remarry or dad remember my mom remarried
brian and my dad's been married helen
yeah yeah johnny got a ryan do i know
it's funny
brian no he's brian yeah yeah ryan
o'brien yeah he's like the ultimate step
dad like you can picture a dude yeah
picture a step dad make zero changes
that's him he works in hydro dude he's
the man like pure step that energy
though and did you take to him right
away
i wasn't around right so it's like like
i was gone when that happens like this
is when i'm in you know college it was
that late so it was not almost like none
of my business so me and him he's like a
friend what would you do if you didn't
have high interest loans or credit card
debt with upstart you can pay off your
existing debt quickly and easily and
start living your life upstart is the
fast and easy way to pay off your debt
with a personal loan all online whether
it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over a million
people have used upstart to get one
fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date so rather than looking at
credit score alone upstart considers
other factors like your income your
current employment and your credit
history to find you a smarter rate for
your loan and you can check your rate
without impacting your credit score in
minutes for loans between 1 000 all the
way up to 50 000 and you can even
receive funds as fast as one business
day after accepting your loan find out
how upstart can lower your monthly
payments today when you go to
upstart.com
honeydew that's upstart.com
honeydew don't forget to use my url to
let them know i sent you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
your income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application upstart.com honeydew between
small talk at the company holiday party
enjoying all the holiday treats your
mouth does a lot this time of year
gifted better oral care with quip makers
of the award-winning electric toothbrush
and when you save up to 40 on holiday
bundles it's also a gift to your wallet
the quip electric toothbrush is loved by
over seven million mouths and has
time sonic vibrations with 30 second
pulses the guided dentist recommended
two minute clean a lightweight and sleek
design with no wires or bulky charger to
weigh you down a multi-use travel cover
that doubles as a mirror mount for less
clutter reusable handles and a range of
sleek metal hues including best-selling
all black and all pink as well as bright
plastic colors sure to add a pop to your
bathroom counter in addition to brush
heads quip also delivers fresh floss
toothpaste mouthwash and gum refills
every three months from five dollars
shipping is free so you can save money
and skip the hustle and bustle of
shopping in store during the holidays
and into the new year even more good
news quip is running their best deals of
the year which means you won't be paying
through the teeth when you gift better
oral health care this year if you go to
get quip.com honeydew right now on top
of their holiday savings you'll get your
first refill free that's your first
refill free and up to forty percent off
of bundles at get quip dot com slash
honeydew that's spelled g-e-t-q-u-i-p
dot-com slash honeydew quip the good
habits company talkspace makes it
possible to speak with a licensed
therapist right from your phone tablet
or computer and unlike traditional
therapy you can message your therapist
anytime via text video or voice it's 100
secure
and stigma free the way therapy should
be you know i believe in therapy this is
a mental health show
um and i believe everybody has something
they could talk to somebody about um
especially guys that that whole like
it's not macho whatever get over that
that's
that's old news man so whether you
struggle with anxiety depression
self-doubt or anything else talk space
gives you access to the help you need to
move forward facing those obstacles
isn't easy and you don't win a prize for
doing it alone getting professional help
isn't weird or weak it's smart because
sure your friend might know a thing or
two about electricity you're gonna let
them rewire your house now join talk
space today and start moving forward
with a single message just visit
talkspace.com and get one hundred
dollars off your first month when you
use promo code honey do it sign up
that's a hundred dollars off at
talkspace.com
promo code honeydew now let's get back
to the duke but my dad he got remarried
which i think i told this story before
but he he got married at the toronto
made beliefs game
no in the middle of a game trap you can
do that yeah so he's actually not
proposed
and everyone wore hockey jerseys at the
gate trash right that's how much they
like hockey he got his wife on board
right
now
but let's
so they got married at they get married
in the middle of the game yeah and he's
not like an empty arena you rent out and
go like this game is happening the game
it's right before the game you have an
area and it's kind of like a box i guess
so that's the thing i used i was like
making fun of him a lot we're all like
this is such trash you're gonna be your
next wedding it's gonna be a nascar and
his attitude was like trash you know how
much this box costs like what are you
crazy
he was like
trash are you out of your mind
white trash can't afford this like
white trash can't afford to look like
white trash that's his [ __ ] yeah yeah
his thing was like what are you out of
your [ __ ] mind it's about the dollar
sign for him
he was impressed that he pulled this off
he was like shut the [ __ ] up where's the
mascot he goes where's the guy
put your hand up if you think this is
too poor for you you can leave
watch the free [ __ ] hockey game what
other weddings do you get to watch a
leafs game
at least sell it every game this is a
big important team
so lobstey loves hockey right
but they they i actually officiated my
mom's uh no
debris
this is when i first started doing
comedy too i was going pretty wild what
was that like i'll tell you a funny one
so my brother's gay
and uh he comes up and he goes
you know uh my stepsister is so happy to
have him in her family because normally
we're just surrounded by guys and then i
went up and i'm like first time he's
complaining about being surrounded by
guys like i'm saying [ __ ] like this
and people in the family are like
probably this is a bad
idea yeah
so i'm i'm officiating the wedding
no
how many people are there
i don't know 200 god that's a lot i'll
tell you if you go back to the uncle
this is the kind of the guy the uncle is
he was there and he wore a do-rag you
know the white guy do-rag yeah he's got
the white guy
he's like the meme and then you know
smokes in the pocket the whole thing and
then we had to drive him back to where
he was staying that night and uh but
like that heroin skinny though oh he's
yeah pure hair and then when we're
leaving
he was he goes to the open bar and he's
trying to take five like cans to go
he's trying to take
[Music]
he's trying to take a bunch of lights to
go right and then
and my mom's like all right this is
gonna
wrap it up
he's not messing around right now you
get that free alcohol kicking
but yeah so i officiated that wedding
then there was the hockey game wedding
and then but again these people weren't
really in my life because i was i was
pretty independent it was like i was
doing my own thing since i was young
right and then i went to college you
know went moved to toronto they you know
met new people liked both of them no you
know so you're basically coming home to
meet their new partners i would come
home to me new partners partners are
cool no problems right you're not being
disciplined and growing up under the
same roof with these people right that's
exactly what it was like i'm sure there
would be millions of problems because i
was a troublemaking kid right but they
didn't have to deal with any of that i
was living my life in toronto you know
why why are you getting thrown out of
school like what kind of stuff are you
doing to get thrown out
i was just like that that kid you know
smart ass loud mouth or were you pulling
off [ __ ] i was a bit of a bit of a
prankster like what to be honest what's
your best prank
and the one that actually got you kicked
out i'll tell you my best prank
so that we this is when i was uh
probably grade nine
so we had uh we pulled this one on a
couple people but there was a french
teacher so in canada you gotta take
french kind of like how you take uh
spanish here we have to have we don't
yeah but we have to yeah right it
doesn't help i took it for 12 years i
can't speak
dude i can barely speak i can say
jennifer paul francis
yeah you dig every year it didn't help
so
we used to do there was like um
there was uh we pulled this multiple
times but the one was miss waldman
that we did it to multiple times she
would they would put movies in and uh
one of the big french ones goes tell the
francaise you ever hear that okay so
they would put those movies in and we
would replace her vhs as with porn nah
yeah so she in high school you got away
with a great night yeah what i didn't
get away with okay
people you got away with with doing it
yeah that was probably one of our best
pranks is replacing all the all the va
what happens when it hits so she just
put it on herself and then it goes you
know bro
old-school porn t-rex brown [ __ ]
and then we go oh
what the
[Laughter]
she went and then she went to the insane
asylum
so you guys deserve that poor lady crazy
yeah we drove that poor lady which i do
feel somewhat bad about now but
she was a bad woman too
she smoked was she running over there to
try to stop the tape and [ __ ] just
panicking or was she just yelling who
did this
panicking but no one ratted on us for
that so they weren't able to pin it on
us that one we got away with but the bet
even
now i forgot about this part but so
she's gone for i don't know if it was
directly rid of that at some point she
leaves for three days which we later
find out she's in the insane asylum
she goes away for three days and the
teacher comes the the supply teacher
comes back and i decide that i'm gonna
pretend that i'm a [ __ ] kid so
that's my thing i go i'm gonna like i
have this whole i don't know it's fun to
do this bit now but you know i i pour my
pants all weird i talked funny and then
i was doing this whole thing like oh you
know and then uh the teacher's back the
next day then she's back the next day
[Laughter]
and then day four she's like yeah yeah
i'm gonna be here for the rest of
semester
and i'm like
so i gotta slowly
next day your pants were on right
i'm like well i can't do this after
another two months that's what you get
i gotta slowly transition out of my
character
i'm like i don't know what that is about
your teaching but i'm back to normal i
don't know what you said man yeah yeah
so i might slowly transition back into a
normal person
yeah she never came back but no you know
what i'm so weird it's kind of funny
because you know what you were talking
about you do comedy and we're it's funny
like a lot of the stuff you used to get
in trouble for you do for a living but i
legitimately
that's what
that's what we're doing the all making
videos causing trouble
we used to go to you know break into
places and film it and do all this [ __ ]
and all this stuff that was everyone
yelling at you like you're you know your
life's gonna be a mess if you don't stop
that's the stuff that you know
eventually and now i make a good living
doing yeah
kind of funny yeah eventually that led
to like the tv shows all that stuff it
was some of that pranks i think back and
i'm like we're doing some pretty funny
ones when we were a kid
tell me um do your mom and dad get along
they don't they're fine now yeah but for
a while my mom it would be very like
um
like passive aggressive like you going
to your dad's like you know i guess uh i
guess he'll probably be doing the way
that he is like it's all that kind of
energy but have they ever been to a show
at the same time to see you do stand up
yeah they just play they're cool but
it's very oh
how's it going i don't think they have
much they don't talk about much
especially now that the kids aren't kids
you know yeah it's good my brother's a
lot younger but now that there's nothing
to talk about i think it's just you know
you know what it is i get some point if
the kids are gone that's someone that
you
dated
20 years ago yeah like there's just
nothing right it's you know you're not
we're going to be friends you know
i'd be insane you're the couples that
they're friends with their ex and the
ex's new husbands they vacation together
they're strange it's it is strange i'm
not down it's a weird little do your own
thing man yeah don't even send pictures
i don't give a [ __ ] i don't care there's
more i think there's more people that
you could be friends with in the world
it just had to be them
yeah um so there was a story you said
that uh
i don't want to give away where you end
up living but
yeah so i remember when i went to uh so
when i went to college this is kind of
like the thing is i always did kind of
good in school so that was it was one of
those things where they're like hey uh
you know you're gonna you're gonna
life's gonna be bad if you don't get it
together for a special needs kid yeah
yeah
you are killing these grapes
yeah so you'd kind of be like i mean i
won't though i'll be you know you're a
kid you're cocky or they're like you're
gonna you know your life's gonna be
messed you're like it won't though i'll
be fine
it wasn't i'd say it wasn't till 25 when
i first was like oh yeah it can go bad
but i remember so when i went to college
in the first like two weeks i got kicked
out of residence and then for what so
we
basically all this stuff so and i met we
uh one of the big things was we i was
throwing parties on the roof then we got
in like a big fight and went through the
window then we we broke in the library
one night and then we were like partying
we threw a party there and we like
brought chicks back to like the library
because
and then just a lot of that stuff like a
lot of just then like all of the little
uh notifications you got like the red
when you only have three all that stuff
but the you know the big things was
breaking all the stuff
uh you know party the party on the roof
was a big one and then i got kicked out
of my res then i got kicked i got kicked
out of all the other ones then i got
kicked out of mine and i remember like
uh i used to then i would so i lived in
my car for a bit so i go but it was
funny why why not with your parents did
you not want to burden or they're two
hours away almost two hours away two
hours away so and also my mom at this
point when she she uh
when she calls me she was like you know
i'm so glad that you're university now
and you like got your act together and
things are going and i'm like i just got
like kicked out like a day ago so i'm
like you know i'm just not gonna tell
them so that they i never told them and
which is even funny because both my
brothers also got kicked out and like at
family things it all kind of be like
yeah at least i didn't get kicked out of
rez and they're just like watch it like
well you're pushing it ryan because they
still don't know yeah
but um so i'm
eventually i would have like you know a
chick or two that i could stay at their
place but it was fun for like a day it
was kind of like oh i'm living in my car
this wild whatever right and then
this girl she was kind of like okay you
can stay here for a couple days but i
sneak in because you basically have to
it's a whole procedure you gotta have
like a watch out man then you get
so i'm going to her thing and then the
someone saw me so the rez come with the
police and they knock on the door
and they were like hey you're like
harboring ryan long essentially and i go
in the closet and the girl she and they
start being like she's like he's not
here and they go listen like you're
going to get kicked out too if you don't
tell on him blah blah and then she just
like looks at me and starts crying
i come out with like the what took you
so long you know
so
so these uh these guys
they take me to the police station then
they're like all right what are the
charges just for all the [ __ ] you've
been doing okay so they're like you're
only allowed and i've been we kind of
i did a few like nights there in jail
like already so and it was like they're
like now you're banned from the rest
except for times you have classes that's
the whole thing and it's like a big
trespass you're only allowed on the
property to attend your class that's
where it got to yeah and this is we're
talking a month into school too this is
pretty early it's interesting that they
don't just say [ __ ] off and throw you
all the way out i guess the res in the
school are different things okay right
so and yeah at this point i'm not going
any classes i'm gonna do anything but
uh school
school first year is pretty easy you
know but the oh no i did get kicked up
so i was in economics and i did i was
showing up to this one class drunk but
like not because i was a mess like
because i thought it was funny and then
eventually they they're like okay you
can do the exams but you can't come to
this class anymore so it's kind of all
this stuff but at the same time like at
the time i thought like i'm yo i'm a
legend like i didn't think
yeah
like
you don't think it's but then so
eventually then it was started being
winter so i was sleeping in my car i had
this like spot and then eventually it
was like too cold so i'm but i'd have
money and i didn't want to tell my
parents i don't have a job i just
so i'm like i was just trying to find
girls i could sleep at their place and
stuff like that but never you know this
stuff kept happening and then i was
sleeping in the car found this one spot
and then the res security came out that
area and they're like hey you can't
sleep here either and then my car
wouldn't start so i'm on the i'm like in
the reds like parking lot the back one
like under a blanket 3am security comes
with the police they're like you can't
be here and i they're like we'll try to
find like a boost so i'm standing there
like in the [ __ ] it's like at this
point it's like december and i'm there
with like the police trying to boost my
car so like and then and then i finally
like 4 a.m go find like a ditch in a
parking lot and like sleep there and i
was like all right i think this is where
we gotta we gotta figure this out
everybody didn't think it could go bad
you're just like yeah yeah now you're
laying in a ditch wondering how it could
go right yeah and no one's watching
no no one thinks this is sick
no one thinks this is fun like i guess i
could tell people like that you know oh
i'm and everyone's just like dude like
yeah it's i think it started to be way
more like dude
get your [ __ ] to get so then i just i
went to hamilton which is kind of like
an hour away and stayed with my like
buddies rez for the rest of the year and
then scrape some money together to get
like a little place where in a room in a
a room like in like a house with like
nine other people off campus but that
was the living in the car there was like
a week and a half where i was
legitimately like
winter just you drive around
canada winter driving around everything
i own dirty in a back of a
car what kind of car uh
caprice classic
yeah no windshield wipers so i would i
would drive with i'd take a hockey stick
and i had a towel on it so
[Music]
that's how i would i would drive with
the oh
that's right that is so [ __ ]
dangerous windshield wipers i had no
cash at this point
eventually i've cashed in my meal plans
he had a meal plan i cashed in my meal
plan and that got me like two grand
that's for the whole thing so that was i
was like we're rich now
but yeah so i would drive around the
caprice classic all my gear there and
then eventually it was like all right
this is we've we've reached the tipping
point but then eventually i kind of then
the band started kind of popping off and
then i was in school while i was like
touring with the band and stuff whenever
finished the degree but that was i think
that was the most like all right we
gotta pull we gotta pull this together a
little bit what um what
what stopped the band
i think that i mean you know looking
back now i think you can look at any
moment in time and be kind of like
you know uh at the time you think it's
one thing but kind of looking back you
know what actually happened i mean
looking back if you look at any
scene and if i look at every band that
was part of that like scene that we're
all popular it's over now for everyone i
kind of think of like it was kind of
like a punk band and we were you know
part of a movement we were one of those
guys i think even whenever you look at
music and even comedy it's like it's
those guys in that scene like there's
the this pocket there's all these
rappers that come from this area or
atlanta or all these uh bands that came
from seattle right
so we were kind of part of this movement
i guess that is over like kind of the
same thing with even take a band like
limb biscuit or something right
like they're still big you know people
still know who they are no one's
listening to the new song it's over you
know what i mean the moment's over
unless you become kind of like a
industry popular band but our movement
was over and i think at the time i maybe
saw it quicker than other people and i
was making these dvds with the bands and
i was probably spending more time on
that like i would everywhere we went i
was just filming all this trouble and we
were releasing all these dvds with the
band and it was kind of getting as much
popularity as the songs at some point so
then i started doing this like weird
live show that i was streaming uh with
all the sketches and all that stuff and
then that led to this weird little cable
access show that we were doing uh that
we had a few sponsors and i was making a
bit of cash on and i was doing this
little cable access show out of our you
know house with a bunch of dudes and
that was just my whole that's all i
cared about so at the same time the
music industry was dying our scene was
over music's a young man's game i was 25
at this point you know it's that touring
in a van and traveling and partying
that's a young man's game
and i think that
even being on the pulse is a young man's
game so right now i a little bit always
try to look at people older than me for
skill and the people younger than me for
energy you know like even that's well
said yeah even the the troublemaking
stuff like i watch these young guys and
i'm like i can't do i couldn't do that
anymore because i don't have the
recklessness i don't have the the
fearlessness but i'm i also don't have
to only get kicked out of places because
i have more tricks in my tool kit you
know right so i think that
uh at the same time that i was you know
becoming obsessed with making videos
that's all i cared about the music thing
was kind of ending and i really want to
do tv shows and so i kind of was
transitioning into that and you did
mention you had a tv show yeah so this
cable tv show led to this show called
ryan long is challenged which was kind
of like an alley g type of thing yeah
which goes right back to your [ __ ]
high school class
bring it back yeah yeah i was always
always always what i called smart stupid
where it's like like i was good at math
but you're stupid like you're loopy
don't know places you know
directions don't know directions don't
have places i'm like the you know very
much
you go you you leave your house because
you and then you realize you forgot your
keys go up go back down forgot him again
go back up i don't you're like a third
time huh like that's
like pieces are missing sort of right
which is one thing i feel like i've
whatever people that have that the real
the only solution is doing one thing at
a time that's the only way to kind of
make yourself not loopy that's my
favorite days you know when we were
talking about days like you know
sometimes you just want to cut the grass
the most days i look forward to is when
i go i'm doing one thing today if it's
editing if it's writing
if it's whatever it is all i'm doing i'm
doing one thing properly and that's when
i think i'm the best too
but
i actually sold this show by doing some
wild stuff i was reading a lot of like
books like
you know like the original kind of take
over the world books like 48 laws of
power and you know that that kind of
what eventually became the tim ferriss
world you know that kind of stuff i was
i felt like i was in the early days of
that where it's like a different way of
looking at life where you're like dude
no you can make it happen
so i would find out the
the heads of all these tv stations and
i'd make all these demos and then i
would find out where they're gonna be
find someone that was there get into the
parties try to like you know make
friends with the people and i managed to
do it to the point where i got to the
head of the party act like i bumped into
the mall and was able to
get them on interest in this show i used
every dollar i had and then went into
debt about 20 grand making
this show so i made six episodes of the
show at first and then sold it to these
guys and
was able to kind of make all my money
back and you know and more and sold this
show when i'm something like 26 and we
made this wild show
and
this was kind of like
in my mind i was like all right this is
what we're doing we kind of got it
figured out now is this also your
introduction into comedy as well out of
the shifting out of the music yeah okay
this is around this time was when i was
like all right i think i got to just do
stand up okay which is maybe 11 12 years
ago
using the internet without expressvpn
it's like leaving your laptop exposed at
the coffee shop table while you run to
the bathroom most of the time you're
probably fine but what if one day you
come out of the bathroom and your laptop
is gone every time you connect to an
unencrypted network cafes hotels
airports any hacker on the same network
can gain access to your personal data
your passwords your financial details
all that stuff your data is valuable
hackers can make up to a thousand
dollars a person selling personal info
on the dark web it's easy to use you
fire up the app and you click one button
to get protected it works on all your
devices your phones your laptops your
tablets and more so you can stay secure
on the go look i love expressvpn i'm
always on the go i got it on my tablet
when i'm flying and traveling i got on
my phone here we've got it here at the
studio we're not going unprotected
secure your online data today by
visiting expressvpn.com honeydew that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com slash honeydew and you can get
an extra three months free
expressvpn.com honeydew green chef is a
ccof certified meal kit company green
chef makes eating well easy with plans
to fit every lifestyle so whether you're
keto paleo vegan vegetarian gluten free
or just looking to eat more balanced
meals green chef offers a range of
recipes to suit your preferences green
chef is the most sustainable meal kit
offsetting 100 of their plastic
packaging in every box and 100 of their
carbon footprint and emissions green
chef offers 35 nutritious and flavorful
options to choose from every week
featuring premium clean ingredients that
are seasonally sourced for peak
freshness and it saves you time by
taking care of meal planning grocery
shopping and most of the prep for you
week after week so you don't have to
they sent me a box of food man you know
i'm jumping right into it i made pork
burgers
i'm telling you it was so good the
barbecue sauce the red onions it was all
there everything you like the cilantro
it's all there it's fresh it's great
it's delicious go to green chef dot com
slash honeydew10 and use code honeydew10
to get 10 free meals including free
shipping listen to me 10 free meals and
free shipping that's greenchef.com
honeydew10 and use the code honeydew10
to get 10 free meals including free
shipping you gotta do it green chef the
number one meal kit for eating well now
let's get back to the do we were doing
wild pranks but this the one that we did
the first episode aired they put all the
press out like it was you know
episode one within 24 hours two of the
people that we pranked had called the
network with their lawyers being like
already lawyered up and this is this
ain't like a huge net this is the
equivalent of like fuse or something
here maybe you know what i mean
like a comedy network but not like
so and
and they're all freaking out we're
getting all these phone calls and it was
it was and i'll tell you what the prank
was which there's kind of so
basically uh it was the every episode i
had to do something wild and it was kind
of like sell a fashion product right so
i made these pants that have a dick
built in to make your deck look bigger i
feel like i've seen this have i seen
this maybe it's like a lot of these
clips went viral yeah but they're called
python pants was the idea
and
[Laughter]
but for real i wonder why no one's ever
solved that i think there's probably
been some version of this after
the original
how long like down on your knees like is
it ridiculous there was some big ones
there was some data oh you had different
sizes
depends on how bad you want to flex you
know
python pants and we so we did
then there was a whole it was a whole
lot everybody's time did you ever give
somebody like well part of the bit was
we would sell them at a store and then
we'd make people come in and then we'd
kind of bully them into buying them and
that was part of that was part of the
bit and we got a few guys to buy them
right um but the uh the main thing was
there's this guy ran this big company
and it was like a big fashion line and i
went in with my crew and i was pretty
good at like weaseling into places so i
went to the front desk and i was like
hey we're here to see the guy who runs
the place and i go he's a friend of my
family and he knows i'm coming or
whatever and they're like what i don't
think we have an interview i'll go no he
knows we're supposed to do a filming
thing with them blah blah and then she
she starts walking and then me and the
crew just follow her because now we can
follow her into his office and then he's
very confused and then we're just like
hey um you know we have the new line for
next year and he's kind of like who are
you and then we like pull out this like
briefcase and it was like python pants
and it was like you know you guys can't
afford not to sell whatever i'm doing
the whole sales pitch he flips out the
security com
he was pissed
and so i
this happens and i'm like
pretty
when all this stuff's going down it was
probably like the because in my mind i
was like the band was you know i'm
making python night pants goddamn
[Laughter]
just a piece
in my mind go to this guy's office and
try to sell dick pants yeah we're like
listen if you're packing you're packing
we're gonna i mean he can't do anything
and his secretary's there
because he says you have an appointment
with me i go
yeah i'm saying all this [ __ ] but the
funny part you're not wearing them in
though you bust you're doing your
presentation wearing them here i've worn
them in other parts though yeah
just a piece
[Laughter]
so he's
when this when they called me i was you
know because this is like the band was
kind of over in my mind and i'm like
yeah i've got my shot to do my tv show
which now it's like now i realize this
tv show was nothing there was no chance
for any of these shows tv was over like
it was so in the past like i was if
anything i was clinging on to the idea
that i could be a you know that tv thing
was over like they'll never have another
tv show like that again especially in
canada that matters but
um so i just went to like i just went um
my my buddy's cabin and i asked if i
could just stay there i went there by
myself and i was you know like feeling
sorry for myself like skipping rocks and
stuff i was telling i told my dad and
then he goes he was yeah i went to high
school with that guy
the guy that i broke into the office nah
i swear to god so the guy got told i
gotta wouldn't buy your dick pants and i
said knew my family
that way yeah he didn't know him
yeah my dad goes i went to high school
with that guy and i go do you think you
could get his number for me because i'm
like what if i could talk him into this
so i eventually my dad goes i'll try he
gives me his number he gets from he goes
my my uncle was buddies with him he gets
the number so i call him and i'm like
hey can i speak too much i tell him it's
the guy that came in with the pants and
then i was like hey um you know i came
in with the pants and um i was just
hoping he goes
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you think that
you could call me after that like we are
gonna [ __ ] take this episode down i
want i'd just go click
listen real quick how do you feel about
python shorts
[Laughter]
you didn't even get out you know my dad
or my dad knows you nothing in my mind i
was like i'll smooth this over
i'm a fast talking salesman
i'm selling python fans i can sell this
guy
in my mind i'm gonna be like you know
we'll
you know we'll recut the parts you
actually i'm going to sell them on
they're like you actually look funny
it's good publicity i'm going to be this
guy right
he's
peeking he like if if you could see him
in person his hair was flying off his
head steam was coming out of the ears
you know he's like you come down here
right now say this to my feet flipping
so i just go click i go all right well
that's not happening eventually
they re-released the episodes with you
know all the stuff cut out four months
later after the hype's over and whatever
kind of dwindling all right so it didn't
make it out then okay i did make it out
but i mean to be fair no one would have
cared at the time but you look back i
think
25 to me you know you were saying 16
things might be before we started but 16
is like a tough age
for me i felt like for a lot of guys
i think that 25 is like the toughest age
especially if you're doing anything
alternative because
tell me why well 25 every
for men everyone is
a lot of people are getting their lives
together they've they've
been out of school for four years people
have a good job but anyone that's doing
something alternative takes a long time
right so i think 25 to 30 for men can
feel
feel for everyone but i think
girls have it at a different time but
for dudes it's like that's the first
where it's like everyone's rushing to
check off all the things people are like
oh you know what i'll have a kid maybe i
could and then it's you look at a guy
that's like 29 you're like dude this guy
lives in a house and he you know he's
got his [ __ ] together he's got making
100k a year and you're like some bum
because you try to do something but then
at 30
i don't even think anyone cares anymore
whether it worked out or didn't
30 is the first year where it's like i
feel like your buddies get together no
one's like hey how's your job no one
cares anymore it's just like i mean even
being a comedian doing this kind of
stuff no one starts being like you don't
go to family things and they go how's
your job they just go how are you yeah
like it's just i feel 30 it's just
whatever you're doing you're doing no
one really you kind of realize no one
cares about you anymore and they don't
which is liberating like people stopped
being invested in you
whether that be your friends whether
that be your family like which can seem
bad to some people but to me it's like
liberating it's like no one's watching
anymore so you're just whatever you're
doing you're just doing it and i think
that that to me
it's kind of like you know the idea of
you can look up and think about how
small you are and it's like that could
be liberating or scary i think it's
liberating you know so i think that the
idea that no one's paying attention to
you anymore to me
gives you the freedom to actually kind
of do
take chances and be you know do what you
want to do
so i think that's why the 30 is like a
tough age
where 16
most people when they're young
especially like a certain type of guy
it's like not that much has gone wrong
yet
bro you don't know who you're sitting
across from
but even still none of that is going to
affect you forever like 16 a lot can go
wrong but it's like it can affect you
mentally no but you can recover from it
you could career-wise like what's going
on i'll give you this though yeah give
me an example of what you mean i'll give
you an example of you're right about
numbers i didn't know
i mean except for my own brothers i
didn't know anybody that went through
what we went through so my dad died my
mom had left our family and my dad died
at 16 and we were on our own from 16.
yeah that's it
so that changed everything for us you
can have terrible things that can affect
you mentally but i only mean so i'm i
think i'm thinking talking about a
different context i'm talking about in
the context of like
are my peers doing better than me oh
yeah yeah you know what i mean they all
were yeah yeah and it's like i think
you drive a company car wait you don't
pay for insurance wait hang on they give
you gas yeah and i'm like what the [ __ ]
am i yeah i'm not much out of here i'm
an idiot and you're like
what am i doing i could have done you
have a 401k and they put money in it
like you're like a real human you're
paid when you're on vacation
yeah i know yeah you
and then
but if you're you ever met a 20 year old
that's like i've made it's too late and
you're like it's like you know what i
mean yeah yeah but there is
some degree you keep reinventing
yourself yeah there's some degree when
someone's like it's 30 and they're like
it's too late you're like yeah probably
like so just do what you're doing now
like or just stick with it not too late
but like yeah whatever you're doing now
it's like it is there is a bit of like
you know you
you're just you're in the pocket now so
i think that that's the pressure is
relieved i think there's so much
pressure when you're just looking around
comparing yourself to everyone
constantly not that that ever ends but i
think it's tougher in your in your
mid-20s i think that's the like toughest
era for comparing yourself to people i
mean look i think you can reinvent
yourself at any point and you have to
but i i think i agree with what you're
saying about people in their 30s i think
if they haven't
gone for it or they're not really in the
middle of it or they just aren't dying
for it that i think a lot of people do
settle if you're then they're gonna take
that job that they've had for 10 years
instead maybe that's a good life it is
it could very well be but if you're
regretting it and always wondering it
like i just know me i'm i don't want to
be a person that you know some of my
last thoughts are what if no i know [ __ ]
that but the probably the type of person
that is like that is the type of person
that took some shots in their 20s
so the fact that you're wired that way
you know you'll kind of have done the
thing where it's like you know i tried a
bunch of stuff in the 20s and
built skills and then in your 30s and
40s you know you can kind of
all all right i'm a formed human i have
some skills that i built let's try to
use them now see what we can do with
this
whereas i think the type of person
there's a lot of people that
that think they want that you know
they'll be like and that's probably at
30 they realize they don't like how many
people are kind of like you know i want
to be an artist i want to do this i want
to start a company and then you're like
i know you you don't you don't want to
do those things you don't want to run a
company you would hate running a company
i know you and then i think at some
point they're like yeah i just think i
like thinking that i'd want to run a
company
you know what i mean so what people get
in touch with who they kind of are at
what what did you first think you wanted
to be did you always know you wanted to
stay in music first
i think that
to me that was just like the cool cool
move at the time did you ever think you
wanted to be anything other than a
musician or a comedian i never thought i
wanted to be a comedian i did think i
wanted to make a tv show i didn't even
know what like i didn't know stand in
front of the camera though yeah like i
know a lot of friends that kind of grew
up that are in comedy that like loved
comedy i didn't watch like i liked
jackass i thought that adam sandler and
david spade were funny but i didn't
watch you know the only stand-up i'd
ever watched was jerry seinfeld telling
you for the last time probably and i was
like all right but no to me it was like
i think that what i realized now
if i look back at what i wanted
it's that
i wanted to do
uh i wanted to like
run my own thing but do it differently
like or do something different like i
think i wanted to live like kind of a
cowboy life
so at the end of the day like a lot of
these lives you end up working 80 hours
a week and you're working just as hard
but there's like some type of like a
pirate
pirate component to it that i think
whenever i feel like the outlaw [ __ ]
whenever i feel that drifting away is
when i really
uh start to feel like ah something's off
you know my i don't i don't like what
i'm doing here even so it's i might be
doing the exact same thing
but it's attached to something which i
think is why the new
industry is so good like even the fact
that the
you know i've i kind of moved here and i
do really well and but i don't think
that the industry like has a place for
me and
it's like they're doing you a favor in a
lot of ways you know because
man listen yes you're right i believe in
that the industry can tell you know all
they want to but there's nobody more
than comedians who have proven this
industry wrong and have gone right over
that wall through that [ __ ] wall
under that wall around that wall if
you're not saying like there's so many
good talented funny musicians comedians
artists and there's this there's this
you know industry this wall that says
we're not saying you're not but we're
gonna you can go you can go you failed
seven times but you can keep on going
yeah you're going again you're going
again you're going again you [ __ ] you
know you can still go you rape people
you can still go but you yeah something
we don't like about you i don't know
what it is and then you got to figure
out your own [ __ ] way
it's better
because because of comedians in our
world it's because of comedians
have taken these [ __ ] podcasts right
here
[ __ ] athletes actors nobody would
took podcasts and took it to this level
like comedians have now everybody's got
a [ __ ] podcast yeah but it was comics
everyone's running a bit they started
that [ __ ] the
rogans and mark maron and hardwick and
god eerwolf guys going way back and
segura and br all these guys were doing
this [ __ ]
way early on and now look where they are
and now everybody's doing it and
everybody's got one but those people the
comedians are the people that have had
to change more than a if you're an actor
you still got to do the same [ __ ] take
your classes learn someone else's
[ __ ] lines
that's it right but for comedians when i
first started
it was just jokes and then it was
wordpress and then it was all these
social media platforms and then it was
get your [ __ ] on video and then it was
this and this and podcasting and it's
like holy [ __ ] we have had to evolve
evolve evolve
more i feel like in art than any other
probably um art form there is out there
i really feel like comedians have had to
just change more than any art form yeah
because the things shifted so quickly so
it feels like
like there's some girl that you like
wants so bad or something like that for
a lot of people and then you kind of you
go get rich and you know it's successful
and your life kind of rules and she's
like you know what i decided i do want
you and you're like what i got for you
even yeah dude like you go to a meeting
now
and it's like
not to like talk about money like that
but it's like let's even say not me but
like a lot of other people that are even
way bigger than me it's like you know a
lot of my friends and me to some extent
you go to these like meetings now and
they're like hey like you know if you
could pitch us this thing maybe you can
get a show and you're like i don't know
if you know this but we're all rich now
like it's like a dude i don't know like
it's like you guys not get like you
missed it and i think that that's why if
they want people they just have to you
know drop like insane deals for people
now because you're just like dude like
my life is good like i'm i do what i
want to do we're making stuff i mean
there's still it's problems like you can
always get deleted and there's there's
still issues with it deleted
you can't
i like that saying that you can delete
it
yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
they disappear your youtube channel you
got deleted he has deleted us
but you know at the same time it is so
there is that thing where you got it's
like you got bullied into doing what you
want to do anyway it's like tough love
almost but then they want to come back
and they're like hey let's do stuff and
you're like what well also just
artistically like
just because you have a good idea
doesn't mean you're going to have
another one
you know what i mean especially one that
was right for that moment
for example you're talking about the
type of music you had and the moment
passed and it was over no energy there
right so but if you're
you had that one good idea well if that
music doesn't last forever there's no
guarantee you're gonna come up with
another band in another genre that's
gonna [ __ ] kill you know you can come
up with a tv show a great tv show
there's no guarantee you're gonna do
another one or come up with a good one
there's no guarantee you're gonna have
another good album another good or but
for entrepreneurs like you know this you
built a company that you're on the pulse
like i think you can look at that for
any business you know it's like i i
think if you're i'm sorry i wanted to
say this because what i'm getting at is
they should pay someone you should want
someone to pay you handsomely for
something that is your [ __ ] passion
and if i'm going to give it up
and i may never have another one again
then for me that financial reward has
got to be worth yeah the fact that i
could you could just you could you
basically you're taking it from me and i
could never have it again today if
that's that's where i would look at it
yeah and you've got to compensate me for
the rest of my [ __ ] life because i
know once i give this up i know that you
people are going to ruin the [ __ ]
thing because that's what you do and
this is the one time that i was
my my like age was right for this moment
my perspective was wrong everything
lined up everything lined up and if
you're going to take it like and then
probably [ __ ] out of me yeah i think
you're right
yeah because there's no guarantee the
stars are lining up again
no what am i going to do there's two
times if it happens a few times in your
life where you're just like man i'm in
the zone on all [ __ ] levels if that
happens a few times in your life that's
probably a pretty decent ratio
i mean if you get one in this business
it's hot yeah
i do that with uh with everything right
now this is like a scott adams thing the
delbert guy but he's like he once said
when you're writing and i think it's for
thinking and for people
but when you're like
use your brain to write but use your
st like stomach and body to find out
when you're excited so it's like you
know that like whether it's a person
whether it's an idea whether it's like a
chick even whatever it's like use your
head for all this you know you might go
you know what i don't think i want to be
with this chick or i don't think that's
the right move and that might be fine
but that can all tell you what's bad but
if you like it you can only listen to
like oh something you're like i don't
know i'm something's getting me going
here prime was happening here yeah
yeah and the more you can like get in
touch with that the more you can kind of
you know like a metal detector you can
be that for
what needs to be said or what needs to
be made or what like you know
what uh what person you need to like add
to your mix you're like [ __ ] this guy
would be a good person in the squad
right now it can be even as simple as
that
so yeah trying to get in touch with that
like
primal that's a good way to put it just
that like what buzzes you up
so yeah i try to
dud this has been a really fun episode
man i've enjoyed sitting here and
listening to you made me laugh [ __ ]
off thanks buddy yeah i know it's been
cool to have dude i like what you guys
have got going here too and i was i was
hanging with josh too and like now you
guys have
you guys have built like a cool little
movement here too it's very uh very cool
to see what like all these different
pockets of people have like built and
just even even watch like how your
operation runs like you know how your
team works and all that stuff like i
think it's cool thank you man we we do
have kirsten's [ __ ] kick ass we got
any working but again
and it's because what we talked about
earlier tom and christina
reaching down and pulling us up you know
and giving us a chance and then it and
also like i don't want to let them down
yeah you know what i mean like you don't
get an opportunity from one of the best
or two of the best in the world at what
they do they're crushing it
and then have them give you a chance and
you just [ __ ] come in and half-ass it
you know what i mean like that's not
that's not what you do with that
opportunity so it's part of it is i want
to be successful but not just for me i
want you know i
i want to make them proud yeah you know
i know that might sound stupid no it
doesn't mean i'm older than tom but but
i want like i don't want you to be like
man you gave me this opportunity and i
say all the time just i hung a shower
curtain up behind me and just started
talking you know like no we're not
the way it's gonna be you need yeah but
you're right you're like no if we're
gonna do this we're gonna do it right go
all in
but yeah you kind of you do need like
yourself to be jazzed up but you do also
need some components of like i mean
that's why standup's cool because you do
get that thing from it where it's like
all right there's a bunch of people
telling me i'm great
and it's immediate that's the other
thing the response that's the heroine
and then you don't become a mess in your
real life whereas you know you need that
trouble to get yourself jazzed up in
real life you can have you can actually
have your life in order and your chaos
can come kind of like you can create it
right on stage your chaos can can be
controlled orchestrated and you still
get the buzz
you're like it's like giving yourself
what's the when they give you instead of
heroin
uh
methadone yeah yeah like laughter and
you know like uh causing trouble like in
your jaw that's like the methadone as
opposed to causing magical trouble
um
dude thank you again uh please plug
promote everything you'd like yeah i do
a podcast every friday um uh and uh
bonus episode on patreon youtube.com
ryanlongcomedy.youtube.com slash the
boys guys with ryan long those are my
two channels every all my socials
instagram twitter everything at
ryanlongcomedy
and uh so this is gonna come on december
i'm i got a special coming out in uh in
january on my youtube channel perfectly
yeah all right man thank you very much
uh as always ryan sickler.com ryan
sickler on all social media we'll talk
to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you